et les césar du meilleur espoir masculin
est attribué à
benjamin voisins c'est le ciel de sa
catégorie qui a déjà été nommé c'était
l'an passé pour étaient 85
sur le balzac nous sommes redonnerait
jeune poète idéaliste des sons fortune à
angoulême
sa relation avec une femme mariée
paris
satisfaire ses grandes jambes si on a
aussi pu cette année dans le bal des
foils sous la direction de mélanie
laurent la pétition on l'a remarqué en
2018 dans la série à fierté de pippo
cour au côté de sammy ou call balit il
vient juste de saluer avant de monter
sur scène chercher son premier césar
[Musique]
bonsoir
merci beaucoup ça fait extrêmement
plaisir je vais
faire de mon mieux pour essayer de
rendre justifier cet espoir à vos yeux
par mon travail dans les prochaines
années
xavier j'ai pas tellement ou thé
sais pas si tu te rends compte de tout
ce que tu m'offres i avec l
indécence générosité tu le fais mais je
t'en serai à jamais reconnaissants
merci à tous ceux qui étaient présents
son plateau il a pas mal ici les acteurs
les techniciens les producteurs les
figurants c'était une belle aventure
j'étais hyper heureux de faire ça on y
attend d'eux quand vous voulez
merci amical laguens d'avoir provoqué ce
choix merci à olivier delbosc et à la
gaumont d'avoir adhéré à ce choix marie
prouser nous sommes tellement travaillé
avec toi alors que les plus belles
années sont devant nous
ma famille mes amis je vous aime je vous
embrasse passer une belle soirée m6 dame
[Applaudissements]